[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
VIJAY GADEPALLY: I hope you all
are enjoying the class so far.
It's always
interesting-- we have
people with a variety
of backgrounds
here, so it's just great to kind
of hear the questions as we're
going along.
So I'm going to
give a quick example
to begin the class right
now that kind of drive
in some of the concepts
that we talked about
on the first class.
But this is kind
of real rather than
sort of cartoon neural networks.
But it's sort of a real
research result that we have.
Before I begin,
I'd like to thank
Emily Do who was one
of my graduate students
who actually did all the work.
I just put some of the
slides together-- not even
all of them, just a few.
So really, the credit for
this work goes to Emily.
Anything I misrepresent
is my fault, not hers.
She graduated, so I'll
take the blame for anything
that's not interesting.
So with that, we'll begin.
All right, so the overall
goal of this project
was really to detect and
classify network attacks
from real internet traffic.
And in order to do this,
as many of you can imagine,
we had to find a data
set that was of interest.
So this is probably
a problem many of you
are currently
thinking about, which
is what data set should
I get my hands on?
Right, so we have a
variety of data sets.
Some are sensitive
in nature, right?
So think of internal
network traffic
that we're trying to collect.
No one's going to let us hand
this over to graduate students
to kind of work on, and then
more importantly, publish.
So the first thing
that we wanted to do
was look for a data set that
was kind of open and out there.
And we're fortunate that there
is a group in Japan called
the MAWI working group, which
stands for the measurement--
and I'll use my cool tool--
the measurement and
analysis of wide area
internet traffic
working group, that
actually has 10 gig
link that they've
tapped using a network tap.
And they actually make
this data available.
It's actually continuously
updated even to today.
So that's really cool,
and this is within that.
It's called the Day-in-the-Life
of the Internet.
And so this has been going
on for multiple years.
The data set is reasonably
large when you convert it
into what we call an
analyst friendly form, which
is something that you or I could
read and make some sense out
of.
It's about 20 terabytes in size.
So a reasonably
large data set, not
going to fit on a single
computer or a single node,
so certainly a good use case
for using high performance
computing or supercomputing.
And one additional piece
that we should note--
and this is something that,
as you're starting off
your projects, you
may also think about--
IP addresses are often seen
as reasonably sensitive.
So you can see where traffic
is coming and going from.
So in this particular
data set, they've
actually deterministically
anonymized
each of the IP addresses.
And as you're
downloading the data,
you have to, essentially,
sign a user agreement saying
that you will not attempt to
kind of go back and figure out
what the original
IP addresses were.
So as you're coming up
with the data sets--
and I think Jeremy is going
to talk a lot more about this
in the next part--
you might think about, you
know, are there certain fields
in the data that I'm collecting
that might be deemed sensitive,
either today or in the future?
And if so, are there
just simple techniques
that I could use to
anonymize the data?
And then with a decent
end user agreement,
you might be able to
enforce some level of people
not trying to break it
and trying to go back.
It's not impossible to do it,
but any legitimate researcher
who is using data
really shouldn't
care about what the
original IP addresses
in this particular case are
or maybe other such data
within whatever your collecting.
All right, so just
a quick definition
of anomaly detection.
I really love this definition
of what an outlier is
from a paper by Hawkins.
So, "An outlier
is an observation
that deviates so much
from other observations
as to arouse suspicion
that it was generated
by a different mechanism."
So when we're looking
at network traffic,
that's what we're looking for.
Right?
We're looking for
these mechanisms that
are present in
network traffic that
deviate so much
from normal behavior
that it arouses suspicion.
And it could be for
a variety of reasons.
It could be somebody uploaded
this cool video of somebody
falling flat on
their face, or it
could be a botnet, or DDoS
attack, or something like that.
So outlier can be
sometimes referred
to as an anomaly,
surprise, or exception.
And within the context
of cyber networks,
these mechanisms can be
botnets, C&C, or command
and conquer servers, insider
threats, or any other network
attacks, such as distributed
denial of service or port scan
attacks.
There are a number
of general techniques
to deal with outlier detection.
So the first one is
to look for changes--
is to essentially
use statistics.
You look at what's going
on in your mechanism,
and you look for statistical
anomalies from that.
And you'll highlight
those anomalies,
and then you'll kind of
drive deep into that.
You could do clustering.
So if you're looking at
unsupervised learning,
you could cluster your data.
And things that
are really far away
from existing clusters,
or known clusters,
are probably something that
you want to take a look at.
You could lose--
Similar to that is also
distance-based techniques.
So these are kind
of closely related
that you look for observations
that very significantly
from other observations in
some sort of a feature space.
And finally, you could use
a model-based technique,
where you attempt to model
the behavior of normal--
right, and I use air quotes
for the word normal--
and then, you come, and you
look for things that deviate
from this background model.
So all of these
four techniques are
approaches to anomaly
detection kind of related
with each other.
It's not a hard and
fast rule about how
they deviate from each other.
But for the popularity and the
complexity of network traffic,
we decide to go with a
model-based technique
because we found that
any other means of trying
to represent the data
would be difficult.
But this is sort of a top
down approach of how we kind
of thought about, well, let's
look at network traffic--
let's think about anomalies
in network traffic-- and let's
come up with what's a good
approach to address that.
So when we talk about
network attacks--
not to go into detail--
there is a wide variety of
network attacks out there.
Every day we see news
articles about new ones.
The focus of this work was to
look at just a couple of these.
One was in this section that
we call probing and scanning,
and another was in this resource
usage or resource utilization
area.
And specifically, we looked at
port scanning and distributed
denial of service attacks.
As a quick example of what
happens in one of these network
attacks-- so this is an attack,
often, within the bucket
of probing and scanning.
So essentially,
what happens is you
have an attacker that
attempts to find out
what ports are open on a
victim or a target system.
It does this by sending
requests, similar to pings,
to a victim or a target system.
If the target's
system acknowledges
one of these things,
you can say, oh,
this particular port is open.
And then, one may go and look
at what software typically
runs on those ports
and attempt to use
some of the known
vulnerabilities
of that software.
So a lot of software
packages have specific ports
that they tend to use.
So you can say, oh,
you know, port--
I'm making up a number,
here-- port 10,000 is open,
and I know that's used
by Microsoft SQL server
or any other piece of software.
And then you can say, well,
here is a known vulnerability
that I could use, and then
I'll try attacking with that.
So this is just a
simple technique
that a lot of attackers use,
very low bar, very easy to do.
You could write one by mistake.
But just to find out
what ports are open,
and then try to use
known vulnerabilities
on different ports.
Now, the least
common denominator,
the easiest piece
of data to collect,
is what's called
the network packet.
I'm sure many of you are
familiar with the concept
of a network packet.
For those that are not, think
of if you're sending a letter,
it's all the material
on the envelope.
So it's the address, where it's
coming from, who it's going to,
plus a little bit of
information of sort of what's
in the package as well.
The reason that we often
use network packets--
and I'll kind of open
this up to the class.
A lot of the cyber
research actually
focuses on network
packets, but those often
form a very small percentage of
the actual data, the payloads,
where actually a lot of
the data actually is.
Can anyone guess why we tend
to use a network packets rather
than payloads?
Not Albert?
AUDIENCE: Header.
VIJAY GADEPALLY: Sorry,
the network header.
Yeah, sorry the network
header, not the packet, yeah.
So, Yes.
Anyone guess why we tend
to use the header rather
than the payload of a packet?
AUDIENCE: Encrypted.
VIJAY GADEPALLY: Yeah,
encryption, exactly.
So very often, especially these
days, the payload of the packet
is typically encrypted,
so there's not too much
that you can do with it.
So using the header
information--
the header is not, right?
It's the outside
of the envelope.
The inside of the envelope is
something that you cannot see
by putting it up to the light.
So that's why we tend to use
the header of the packet.
So the headers-- so this is
what a packet looks like,
on the left.
On the left side, that's
what a packet looks like.
And if you kind of convert
that into a human readable
form, just the
header information,
this is the type of data
that you get out of it.
So it gives you things
that you would expect.
What was the IP address
that I started from?
What was a port
What was the
destination IP address?
What was the destination port?
Plus a bunch of
other information
about certain flags that
were set, whether it's
what direction to flow--
what direction the
traffic is moving in
and stuff like that, and then
any flags associated with it,
what type of packet it is,
so what type of protocol
is the packet using, et cetera?
All right, so just as a
reminder, the data we're using
is from the MAWI
working group, but there
is a lot of other data
out there that you might
be able to get your hands on.
So one of the challenges,
how many people here
have worked in
cybersecurity or done
some research in cybersecurity?
So a handful of people.
So one of the huge challenges--
this is something that you may
run into in your data sets--
is ground truth, is
understanding when--
So if you're trying
to find out when there
was an attack in
your data, someone
needs to have-- you
know, there needs
to be some ground truth
associated with that.
As much as we'd all
love to sit and write
DDoS attacks and
port scan attacks
on ourselves, sometimes, you
know, getting that at scale
can be very difficult.
So for the purpose
of this work, we
used a synthetic data
generator, in which
we took real
internet traffic data
but then injected
synthetic attacks into it.
And that was sort of our way of
looking for-- of establishing
ground truth.
So the MAWI working
group actually
does published ground truth
based on a number of detectors
that they have.
A lot of these are
heuristics-based detectors.
In our use and in our
looking at that ground truth,
it was really difficult
to actually understand
when an attack was occurring.
It was sort of like,
somewhere in this hour
an attack occurred.
Which, if you're trying to train
a machine learning classifier
on that or an anomaly
detector, that's kind of vague.
Because there's a lot happening
in an hour of internet traffic,
and so if it's somewhere in
that hour an attack occurred,
that can be very
difficult to find.
So that's sort of
a reason that we
focus on using a synthetic
attack generator.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Can you
say a little bit more
about what kind of
data gets contracted?
You know, is it
just additive, where
you're showing some
new compromised
post that is injecting
data to some destination?
Is there also, like, return
flows that are in there?
VIJAY GADEPALLY: Yep.
AUDIENCE: OK.
VIJAY GADEPALLY: Yeah, so
the question that was asked
is, you know, I guess, how
sophisticated is this tool,
and how detailed can you do it?
So the exact details of that,
I would probably forward you
to Emily, but from looking
at what was being done,
these are reasonably
sophisticated.
So it's not as
simple as, you know,
you have to give it a text
file, all the IP addresses,
source and--
But you do have to
set some parameters.
So what you can do, for example,
if it's a DDoS attack-- right,
that's maybe the easiest
one to describe--
is you would give maybe a
range of IP addresses and ports
that you'd like to see injected,
you'd give it a flow rate,
and then you could tell
it what type of packets
you'd like introduced.
And it sort of allows you to do
a number of these different--
this particular tool at least--
allows you to pick a number
of these different features
that it then injects into
the original pcap file.
If you're looking for some
of the other attacks--
so this is just a
list of the attacks
that they currently support,
as of a few months ago,
and they might be
adding to this.
You know, we focus on a
few of these that were also
easy for us to
reason and, kind of,
go back into the
actual data that we
collected to see if the actual
injection made sense to us
or not.
But we do have a number
of different parameters
that you could pick
when you're doing that.
So that's just a little bit--
You know, as we talked about,
in the data conditioning
phase of the labeling
data, is often
a pretty difficult process.
In the world of cyber
anomaly, in the world
of network packets
and network security,
going back and trying to label
is an extremely time consuming
task and very difficult and
up to a lot of interpretation
as to what one calls an attack.
So while we did manually
inspect a few of these,
and that's certainly
not scalable.
So we decided to go with a
synthetic attack generator.
And I'm sure for some
of your projects,
you may also kind of
think about is that
a route that you need to take,
at least to start off with.
OK, so this is the overall
pipeline of the system.
So as I mentioned the
first time we chatted,
we spent a majority of our
time in the first step here,
which is data conditioning.
So within data conditioning,
we did, you know,
taking the raw data,
which is downloading this
from the internet.
This comes to you in a binary
format, which is a pcap.
For those who are familiar with
packet capture outputs, that's
that binary format
that comes from,
like, tcpdump, for example.
We then convert that
pcap file into flows,
parse that into
human readable form,
feature engineer, training
machine learning classifier,
do the same thing with
the synthetic data,
and then get good results.
Or we hope that you
get good results.
So step one of data
conditioning was
to download the actual raw data.
The data was downloaded
in a compressed binary
format, which is probably
what a lot of you
will get your hands on.
A typical size of a single zip
file or typical compressed file
is about two and a half gig.
When you decompress that,
it goes to about 10 gigs,
so about 4 x.
And a single pcap
file corresponds
to-- so it's about 10
gigs for about 15 minutes
worth of traffic.
So if you're trying
to do multiple days,
you can imagine how this starts
to explode in terms of volume.
And about 15
minutes, on average,
is about 150,000 pack--
it corresponds to about
150,000 packets per second.
So this a reasonable
amount of network traffic
that we're getting our
hands on, but not even
close to the types of volume
that large scale providers
have to deal with
on a regular basis.
Once we have the actual--
once we have the
pcap file downloaded,
just the network packets
don't really tell us much.
It's stuff to do things with.
So what we want to
do is convert this
into a representation that's
useful to do analysis.
And so a lot of work has been
done using network flows.
And a network flow
is, essentially,
a sequence of packets from a
single source to destination.
So as you can imagine, when
you're streaming a YouTube
video, for example, it's not one
big packet that comes to you,
but it's a series of packets.
And so flow essentially
tries to detect that
and say, OK, all
of these things was
a person watching this video.
Right?
So from this source to this
destination within some time
window is defined
as a network flow.
And so we convert each of
these 15 minute pcap files
into network flow
representation using a tool
called yaf, which stands
for yet another flow meter.
And so that helps us
do some of this flow--
establishing these
network flows.
And so the size of about
15 minutes worth of flows
goes to about two gigabytes,
and we set a time out of flow
to be about five minutes.
OK, once we have
the flows, they're
still in this binary format.
We need to now convert
them into a representation
that we can look at.
So flow comes with an ASCII
converter called the yafscii--
Sorry, yaf comes with the
ASCII converter called yafscii,
and that essentially converts
the data from this floor
representation into
a tabular form.
And if there's one
lesson that I think
Jeremy will talk to
you a lot about next,
it is tables, tables, tables.
People love looking
at tabular data,
it's very easy to understand.
I wouldn't recommend it, but
you could open this up in Excel.
It would be huge,
but it would open up.
But it's very easy
to, kind of, look at,
especially when we're trying
to establish truth in the data
and go back and
take a look at it.
So for our pipeline,
we take the yaf files,
convert them into text files.
Each of these ASCII
tables, so again,
about 15 minutes worth of
data, is about eight gigabytes
in size.
And we record a number of
different data pieces per flow.
I won't go into the details,
but if you're interested,
you can kind of look at what
are the various entities
or features that come
up in a network flow?
So now that we
have network flows,
that's sort of like part one
of data conditioning, right?
We've converted it into
some representation
that makes sense.
We have it in human
readable form.
So, step one data
conditioning done.
Now, the next thing
is to convert it
into something that
actually makes sense
for our machine
learning algorithm.
And so this is sort of bucketing
into the area of feature
engineering, when we
kind of think back at it.
And so feature engineering
is really, really important.
You'll spend a lot of time
doing this on new data sets.
And so, each of
these flows contains
about 21 different features.
And one of the--
we need to look for essentially
which of these features
makes sense for us to pass
into a machine learning model.
Others we're just going to end
up training on a [? noisy. ?]
So we have to use some
domain knowledge, right,
where we talk to
experts in cybersecurity
and say, well, you
know, IP address is kind
of an important thing, but
maybe this other flag is not
as important.
And then, we use a lot of
trial and error and luck,
as well, to help pick
some of these features.
Once we have these--
Once we kind of pick
a set of features
that we're interested
in, when we look back
at the anomaly detection
literature, a lot of work
has been done with
this concept of,
you know, you have
these flows, but you
need to convert them into some
other format that makes sense
to look for anomalies.
So it's just converting
into a feature space
in which anomalies make sense.
And so we looked
at using entropy.
And the basic
intuition behind this
is that if we're
looking at various flows
between different fields and
that the entropy of these flows
should be roughly equal--
should be roughly
similar, should
be about the same,
not equal-- but should
be unchanging when there is
no big mechanism, defined
by an outlier
detection mechanism,
that's involved with
changing the entropy.
So for example, just to
make this more clear,
if you're having a
DDoS attack, this
is typically a number
of different source IP
addresses attempting to talk
to a single destination IP
address.
So you would expect
to see an increase
in the entropy of
the source IP field
in that particular example.
And in port scan attacks,
you would probably
see something on the destination
port entropy would go up.
Right, that's a little
bit of intuition,
it's a little bit more
complicated than that.
But that's a very high level
view of what's going on.
And for entropy, we
just use the standard--
I'm sure many of you who are
familiar with information
theory are very familiar
with Shannon entropy.
And we compute the
flow associated
with each of the features that
we pinged from the network flow
before.
So from the feature
engineering, we
picked a subset of features
associated with that.
We all remember when
neural networks are.
This is just there
for completeness.
So we take these
now, network flow
sees these entropies associated
with the network flow,
we use those as input features
for a neural network model.
Now, you'll recall from
the neural network talk
that we had last week, we
have inputs and outputs,
we have weights
associated with them,
and then we have this
nonlinear equation that
sort of represents inputs and
outputs at each of the layers.
That was the equation.
I could see Barry giving
me the cue that I'm
walking towards the slides.
AUDIENCE: Oh no.
VIJAY GADEPALLY: So the
features that we have over here
correspond to the
various entropies
that we've computed
in the previous step.
And the outputs of
this network correspond
to a class of attack.
So in particular, we
focused on, obviously,
no attack, DDoS attacks,
port scans, network scans,
and P2P network scans.
The model itself had three
hidden layers with 130
and 100 nodes, respectively,
and an output layer.
And we used ReLU activation.
I'm happy to talk in more depth
about why we selected these,
but I'll save that
for another time.
And going through this
process, we actually
had very good results.
So that's sort of the short
form of the research work.
But what I wanted
to really emphasize
is the amount of effort
that went into the data
conditioning, the importance
of collecting data, anonymizing
data, making it human readable,
converting it into a format
that people understand,
and then kind of walking
through the sort of-- it was
certainly an iterative process.
As much as this is a very
short form of what we did,
this took a long time
to get to these results.
And what we're
presenting over here
is the attack type
and the intensity.
So this is the ground truth from
the synthetic data generator,
and then this is sort
of the prediction
that our model has
across the site.
And this is a confusion matrix.
So a higher number
or a darker blue
indicates that we did
a really good job.
And we've also used
varying intensities
of these in attacks.
So certainly, if we
have strong, which
means we've injected about
20,000 packets in the 15
minutes, we can detect
those really, really well.
As you have weaker
and weaker attacks,
our system doesn't do as
well. it's quite reasonable,
but certainly an area
of ongoing research.
So with that, I just wanted
to hand it over to Jeremy.
But these are some
initial work and results
of detecting and
classifying network attacks.
The keynotes was--
data conditioning
was where we ended up spending
the majority of the time.
Cleaning up the collected
data, coming up with--
We spent a lot of time
trying to figure out
how to label this data
because we were just
unable to really do it.
And finally, we ended up going
the synthetic generator path.
But we actually did spend a
significant amount of time
to try to figure that out.
And then, we spent a
lot of time and feature
in engineering,
which did consist
of a lot of trial and error and
a lot of that stuff like that.
OK, thank you.
JEREMY KEPNER: OK,
thank you very much.
I'm Jeremy Kepner from
the Lincoln Laboratory
Supercomputing Center.
I think most of you
know me already.
I'm just really introducing
myself for video.
And this has been his topic
has been teed up really
well by Sid and Vijay.
I think they illustrated,
sort of, going from--
if we think about our pipeline
going from left to right.
So they've talked
about, kind of,
the end stage of what
you're trying to do
and building these models.
Vijay talked about the
data that feeds into that.
I'm going to talk about
the data architecture
that you go through to
kind of build up to that.
And the reason we've done
it in this order, which
is the reverse order that
you do it in real life,
is because it's difficult
to appreciate the data
architecture piece without an
understanding of where you're
going.
And so if you see
from Sid's talk,
I think it became very clear
that having lots of data
is really important for
creating these models.
Without the data, you
can't do anything.
And likewise, you didn't
see it, but all that data
was created in a very
precise form that made it
easy to do that kind of work.
And then, Vijay talked a
little about some of things,
given a data set
what did he have
to do to get in and form such
that it would work for his AI
training application.
And what Vijay is doing and
did in that application,
is very much a sort of
microcosm of which many of you
will be doing in
your own projects.
You will try to
identify data sets,
you will try and do
featuring engineering,
and then go through this
sort of trial and error
process of coming up with AI
models that suit some purpose.
And a key part of that is what
we call AI data architecture.
So I'm going to talk
about some of the things
that we've learned over the last
10 years in data architecture.
As a head of the
supercomputing center,
I have the privilege of
working with, really,
everyone at MIT on all their
data analysis problems,
and over the years, we've
learned some techniques,
some really simple techniques,
that can dramatically
make data architecture for your
applications a lot simpler.
There's a lot of
people out there
selling very fancy software
to solve data architecture
problems.
We have found that we can
use very simple techniques
to solve most of those
problems using software
that's built into every single
computer that is made today.
That is, you don't
need to go and download
some new tool to do
any of the things I'm
going to talk about right now.
So with that introduction,
I'm going to just go over
this the outline of my talk.
I'm going to add some
introduction and motivation,
which I'll go through
quickly because I think
Sid and Vijay did a fantastic
job of motivating what we're
doing.
And then, I'm going to talk
about our three big ideas
and how to make AI
data architecture
simple and effective across
a wide range of applications.
One is, and as
Vijay talked about,
we're going to really hit
this concept of tabular data.
There's a reason why
tabular data is so good
and why it is such
a preferred format.
And so, you want to
try and get your data
into these tabular formats.
And the nice thing is that,
if that sounds really simple,
it's because it
is really simple.
Lots of people,
though, want you to buy
tools that make this
process complicated
because that's how they inject
themselves in the process.
And we've discovered,
actually, you
can do world class MIT quality
AI work with really, really
simple tools.
Getting things in a tabular
form is a great starting point.
And then, how to
organize the data,
how to organize the data in
the pipeline that Vijay showed,
which is pretty standard
across a lot of applications.
Again, there's lots of
applications and tools
that we'll will to
do that for you.
We've just found that simple
folder naming and file naming
schemes gets you a long way.
They require no
tools, and they make
it really easy for other
people to join in your project
because they can just
look at the data,
and it's pretty clear
what's going on.
And it also makes the
data easy to share.
So that's another simple thing.
And then finally, I want to talk
about every single application
we've demoed here
involve data steps that
were designed for sharing.
Designing your data such that
you can give it to others
actually addresses a lot
of the data architecture
problems that you will
encounter yourself.
By thinking about, OK, how do
I make this data such that I
can give it to
someone else, you're
really making a much better
product for yourself.
You're making it so
that other people
can join your team
much more quickly
and be much more effective.
And so, thinking
about sharing of data
is really an important thing.
And what you'll discover is
that generalize sharing of data
is very hard.
Just pointing to a
data set and saying I
want to share it is
very challenging.
There's a lot of
barriers to do that.
But if you have some idea
what the end purpose is,
what the particular
application that you want
to share this data for, then
it becomes a lot easier,
both technically and
administratively.
And we will talk a
little bit about some
of the administrative
burdens that you need
to go through to share data.
And this is where knowing the
purpose, in this case, we want
to do particular AI
application, dramatically
simplifies the process
of doing data sharing.
So just some motivation,
this is a slide
that Vijay presented earlier.
And the big thing
to emphasize here
is we have a bunch
of breakthroughs,
and the key is the
bottom row, which
says that the time from
algorithm to break through
is, like, two
decades, but the time
from getting data set that is
a shareable, well architected
data set to break through
was much, much shorter,
was only three years.
And so that's, kind of,
motivation for the fact
that why data is so important
to making progress in AI.
The data is actually
writing the program,
as Vijay mentioned
in the first lecture.
And so having data
is really important.
And it has been often
observed that 80%
of the effort associated
with building an AI system
is data wrangling, or data
architecture, as we call it.
And one of the benefits of
these challenge problems,
or these open and
shareable data sets,
is that they have done a lot of
the data architecture and data
wrangling for the
community, which
is why they're able to have
a lot of people work on it
and make progress on it.
If you're doing a
new application,
you have to do this data
architecture and data
wrangling yourself.
And we're going to share
with you the techniques
for doing that effectively.
And I would say,
in most situations,
this 80% of the
effort actually is
going to discovering the
methods that we are going
to cover in a few minutes.
That is, it takes people
a long time to figure out,
oh simple tables are good.
We can organize
our data that way.
And just having a good set of
folder names and file names
really solves most of
the problem, right?
That's the beauty
of the solution.
It sounds so
phenomenally simple.
How could it possibly work?
That's actually--
you know, if there's
one thing we figure
out here at MIT,
it's that simple can be
very good and very powerful.
So as was mentioned before,
sort of these neural networks,
as depicted here, drive
this space of applications.
Most of the innovations we've
seen in the past few years
have been using these
neural networks.
This one slide sort of covers
all of neural networks.
In one slide, you
have the picture,
you have the input features,
which are shown in gray dots,
you have the output
classifications
that are shown in
blue dots, and then
you have their neural
network and all
their various weight matrices
or weight tables in between.
If you had one goal, in
terms of understanding AI,
making a commitment to
understanding this one slide,
then you pretty much
understand a good fraction
of the entire field.
And while you are
here at MIT, please
feel free to talk to any
of us about this slide
or these concepts and
we will work with you
to help you understand it.
Because anyone who's
ever coming to you
and offering an AI solution
that uses neural networks, which
is a significant fraction of
them, they're just doing this.
This is all they're doing.
It's all on this one slide.
Many of them, by the
way, do not know the math
that one equation here
that's in this this.
They have software,
they play with knobs,
but they don't even understand
the underlying mathematics.
And just understanding this
math, taking the time to do it,
you will know more than
anyone who is actually trying
to sell you AI solutions.
Now, as Sid said, he
talked about batch size--
I just added batches
to this figure
to emphasize the fact
that all of these letters
are mostly uppercase.
And if you want to know one
thing about matrix math,
it is the easiest way to
go from a vector equation
to a matrix equation is to
take all the lowercase letters
and make them uppercase.
And most of the time,
that actually just works.
In fact, typically
what we do if you're
a linear algebraic
person, is we do that,
and see if it breaks anything.
And if it doesn't
break anything,
well, we assume it's right.
And all of these matrices,
right, are tabular.
A matrix is just a big table.
It's a great big spreadsheet.
So basically, all of
neural networks in AI
is just about taking
spreadsheets and transforming
them.
And so, this is just
motivation for why
these tables are so important.
Here is the standard pipeline.
Vijay talked about it briefly.
And again, what we discovered
is that, in most data
analysis, which includes
AI, this pipeline
represents, pretty much, what
most applications are doing.
It's not that any
application does all of that,
but most of the steps
in an application
fall into this pipeline.
Basically, you have raw
data, you parse it, usually
into some tabular format, you
may ingest it into a database.
You then query that database
for a subset to do analysis,
or you might scan
the whole database
if you're doing all
the files, if you
want to do some application
that involves all the data.
And then, you analyze it,
and then you visualize it.
And so, this is sort of
the big steps in a pipeline
that we see.
And again, most
applications that we'll will
use three of these steps.
They're not using
all of them, but it's
a great framework for looking
at any data analysis pipeline.
It's easy to use, it's
easy to understand,
and it's easy to maintain.
And you know, we like
all of those features.
And I'll get into
those in more detail.
And then finally, I've already
talked with significantly
about data sharing.
There's just some
examples of data
we've put up for sharing,
the moments in time
challenge, the graph challenge.
And again, creating,
sharing quality data,
really, it's not just a
service to the community.
It's principally a
service to yourself.
And in fact, we've worked
with a number of applications
and sponsors where
we help them do this,
and they find the data that
they made shareable is instantly
the most valuable data
in their organization
because it's shareable within
their organization too.
The same things that make
it shareable to the broader
community make it shareable
within your organization
to other partners.
So that's really important.
And again, as I said
before, co-designing
the sharing and the
purpose of the data,
is quite you need to do that.
In order to do
effective sharing,
you can't just share
data arbitrarily.
That can be very
difficult to do,
but if you have a particular
application in mind,
sharing the data
is quite simple.
And I'll get into that later.
So I'm just going to,
then, sort of hammer home
some of these points, here.
So nothing really
new, here, just sort
of repeating what I've already
said about these things
but with adding a little
bit more texture, to them.
So why do we like tables?
Well, we've been using
tables to analyze data
for thousands of years.
So on the right is a
12th century manuscript.
It's actually a table of pies.
And if you can read
Latin and Roman numerals,
you already can tell it
is probably, oh, there's
some columns, and
there's some rows.
And those Roman
numerals are numbers.
Even 800 years
later, we can still
see that this is a data table.
And it goes back further.
You can find cuneiform tablets
that are thousands of years old
that are clearly written
in a tabular form.
So humans have been looking
at data in a tabular form
for thousands of years.
Part of that is how our
brain is actually wired.
One, the 2D projection,
since we live in 3D space,
is the only projection
that will show you
all the data without occlusion.
So if you want to
look at all the data,
it kind of has to be
presented in 2D form.
We have a 2D optical system.
In addition, we have special
hard wired parts of our eyes
that detect vertical and
horizontal lines for,
presumably, detecting
the horizon or trees
or who knows what.
And that makes it
very easy for our eyes
to look at tabular data.
And because of
this, tabular data
is compatible with
almost every data
analysis software on earth.
If I make data analysis
software and it
can't read tables
or write out tables,
it's going to have a
very small market share.
And this is just an example of
some of the software out there
that is designed to use tables.
So whether it be spreadsheets or
databases or the neural network
packages that we've
already looked at,
various languages and
libraries, and even
things that you
wouldn't think are
tabular like hierarchical file
formats, like JSON and XML,
can actually be made compatible
with a tablet format.
So I'm just going to
walk through these
in a little more detail.
So of course, our
favorite is spreadsheets.
Here's an example of a
spreadsheet, on the left.
And what's great
about it is that I
have four different types
of data that are very, very
different, and you
can all look at them
and sort of get a
sense of what they are.
And that just shows how flexible
this tabular spreadsheet
form is, is that we can handle
really, really diverse types
of data in a way
that's intuitive to us.
Some of the biggest
pieces of software
that are used that
implement this
are Microsoft Excel, Google
Sheets, Apple Numbers.
It's used by about 100
million people every day.
And so, this is the most popular
tool for using data analysis,
and there's a good
reason for it.
And thinking of things
in a tabular format
so they can be pulled
into this really makes
communication a lot easier.
And so again, just sort of
hammering home this element
of tables.
Within that, there's
specific formats
that we have found
to be very popular.
So CSV and TSV are just
non-proprietary, plain text
ways of organizing data.
We highly encourage people
to use them because then it
can be used by any tool.
CSV just stands for
comma separated values.
It's usually filename.csv in
lower case or filename.CSV
in upper case.
And all it means is
that the columns--
So each row is terminated by a
new line, and within each row
the columns are
separated by a comma.
That's all that means.
We tend to encourage
people to use
TSV, which stands for
tab separated values,
because we can replace
the comma with a tab.
And that allows us to
write higher performance
readers and writers.
Because it is not uncommon to
have a comma within a value,
and so it makes it very
difficult to write parsers
that can do that fast.
But it's OK to say to a
person generating data,
if you put a tab inside a
value that's a foul on you.
You shouldn't do that.
And so that means I can
write a program that
can read this data
really fast, and it can
write this data really fast.
And that's why, in the
big data or AI space,
people often tend to use TSV.
And again, it's easily
readable and writable
by all those
spreadsheet programs
that I have said before.
Databases play a very
important role as well.
There's several different types
of databases that are called
SQL, NoSQL, and NewSQL .
They're good for
different things.
I won't dwell on that
here, but there are
different types of databases.
All of them operate on tables.
In fact, the central
object in a database
is literally called
a database table.
And so, databases play
an important role.
I won't go into detail here,
but I just want to mention this.
Likewise, you've already
had some demonstrations
of different languages
and libraries.
I think everything
you saw was in Python.
There's other languages--
Julia, MATLAB, Octave, R--
many other languages
that play important roles
in data analysis.
We've talked about
Jupyter Notebooks, which
is a universal interface to
these different languages
and libraries to allow you to
do data analysis in addition
to the various machine
learning tools.
We've talked a lot
about TensorFlow,
but there's others--
Theano, Caffe, Nvidia Digits--
all are examples of
different tools for doing AI.
And again, they love
to ingest tabular data,
and they're very good at writing
out tabular data completely
consistent with that here.
And then finally, I want
to mention XML and JSON,
which are very popular in
object-oriented languages,
like C++, Java, and Python.
Those languages rely on data
structures, which are basically
just a set of fields,
and then those fields
can also be data structures,
and this can continue on.
These are called
hierarchical data structures,
the way these languages
are organized.
And so it's very natural
for them to have formats
that they can just say, write
out this whole blob of data,
and it will write it out into
a hierarchical form called
XML or JSON.
However, it's not
very human readable.
And I just told you that
all the data analysis tools
want tables, which means
that these formats aren't
necessarily very good for
doing data analysis on.
Fortunately, we've
discovered some ways
that we can basically convert
these hierarchical formats
into a giant, what we
call, sparse table.
And sparse just means a table
where lots of the values
are empty.
The entries are empty.
And so we can just
use that space
to represent this
hierarchy, and all the tools
we've just talked about can
ingest this data pretty easily.
Because tables are so popular,
every single different approach
or software package--
and we have a bunch of them
listed in the first column,
here--
assign different names
to the standard ways
we refer to the
elements of a table.
And there aren't that many.
So when you think
about a table, there's
certain standard terms
for dealing with what
do we call the table?
In Excel it's called a sheet.
How do we refer to
a particular row?
What do we call a whole row?
How do we refer to
a particular column?
What do we call a whole column?
What do we call an entry?
And what kind of
math can we do on it?
And so, whenever
you're encountering
a new piece of software--
And we deal with it all the
time, but a lot of times
you'll get software, and
maybe it's related to data
analysis seems really,
really confusing.
It's probably working on
tables, and so all you
have to need to learn is what
are they calling these things.
And different software
gives it different names,
just for arbitrary
historical reasons.
And so, if you can figure out
what it's calling these things,
then you'll discover
the software
is a lot easier to understand.
So we definitely encourage you
to just map whatever software
into these concepts,
and all of sudden life
becomes a lot easier.
And because tabular data
is used so commonly,
whether it be in spreadsheets
or analyzing graphs or databases
or matrices, it's a
natural interchange format.
So by reading in tabular data
and writing out tabular data,
you're preserving your
ability to have that data go
into any application.
Again, you have to be
careful about people
who want to write
proprietary formats
because they're
basically, sort of,
preventing you from
basically working
with other tools and
other communities.
And this is another reason
why tabular data is so great.
All right, so moving on
here, I wanted to just talk
about basic files and folders.
So hopefully, you
know, tables are good.
That's sort of lesson one.
And we're going to talk about
how files and folder names,
well chosen is also good.
Right?
Again, this sounds so obvious,
but it's really the thing
that we've discovered,
in working with thousands
of MIT researchers
over the past decade,
that these are the
fundamentals that help you out.
I've already mentioned this
pipeline that we talked about.
It's a way we organize the data.
It's easy to build.
It has built in tools
in every single computer
you have to support this to
just create folders and files.
That means it has
no technical debt.
That is, you never have
to worry about if you
have folders and files
that in 10 years,
oh my god, folders and
files are going to go away.
They've been around
for 50 years,
in pretty much
their present form.
We don't anticipate
them changing.
They're easier to understand.
I already talked about
tabular file formats
and how useful they are.
And we will talk
about a simple naming
scheme for your data files.
AI requires a lot of
data, which means,
often, thousands or
millions of files.
Having good schemes for naming
them really helps you and helps
share the data amongst
people in your team.
They can just look at
the folders and files
and sort of understand
what's going on.
And again, this folder structure
is very easy to maintain,
doesn't require any
special technology,
and anyone can look at it
Getting into some more details
about this table format,
some sort of real, sort of in
the weeds types of things that
are really important.
I've always talked
about you want to avoid
proprietary formats if you can.
Using CSV and TSV are great.
They might be a little bulkier.
You can compress them.
No problem with doing that.
Then you get pretty
much all the benefits
of a proprietary format but in
a way that's generally usable.
Within a TSV or CSV
file, it's good practice
to make sure that each
column label is unique.
So that's actually a big help.
You don't want to
have, essentially,
the same column label or column
name occur over and over again.
And likewise, it's helpful if
the first column are the row
labels, and those are
each unique as well.
And just those two practices
make it a lot easier
to read and organize the data.
Otherwise, you end up having
to do various transformations.
If a lot of the entries
are empty, i.e.,
the table is very sparse,
there's another format we use,
which is sometimes
called triples format.
Basically, every
single entry in a table
can be referred to
by its row label,
it's column label,
and it's value.
That forms a triple.
So you can just write another
file, can be a TSV file,
that has three columns.
The first column
is the row label,
the next column is
the column label,
and the next column
is the value label.
And most software can
read this in pretty nice--
it's a very convenient
way of dealing
with very, very sparse data
without losing any benefits.
So that's a very good thing.
In terms of actual file
naming, as I said before,
you want to avoid having
lots of tiny files.
Most file systems,
most data systems,
do not work with small
files really well.
You do want to compress.
Decompression doesn't
take much time.
It's usually quite beneficial.
And so, it's better to
have fewer larger files.
A sweet spot, for
a long time, has
been file serving the one
megabyte to 100 megabyte range.
This one megabyte
is big enough so
that you can read it in
and get high bandwidth,
get the data into
your program quickly.
And up to 100 megabyte, once
you start going beyond that,
you maybe can start exhausting
the memory of your computer
or your processor.
So this is one megabyte
to 100 megabyte
range has been a sweet
spot for quite a while.
You want to keep directories
to less than 1,000 files.
That's pretty common nowadays.
Creating directories with a
really large number of files,
most systems don't
really like that.
You'll find it's also
hard to work with.
And so, that's something.
You want to keep your
directories less than 1,000.
And so, you do that by using
hierarchical directories.
And so, when it
comes to naming files
to things that tend to
be pretty universal,
is source and time of data.
Right?
Where you collected it
and when you collected
it are pretty fundamental
aspects that you
can rely on being a part
of almost all data sets.
And so, this is a
simple naming scheme
that we use that we
find is very accessible.
We just create a
hierarchical directory here.
It begins with
source, and then we
have the years, the months, the
days, the hours, the minutes,
however far you need
to go to kind of hit
your sort of 1,000
files per folder window.
And then, we repeat
all that name
within the file name itself,
so that if the file ever
gets separated from its
directory structure,
you still have that information.
And that's really important
because it's easy for files
to get separated,
and then, you know,
it's like a kid wandering
around without his parents.
But if it's got a little
label on it that says,
this is my address, then you can
get the get the kid back home.
And likewise,
sometimes you'll do
the time first and then source.
It really depends
on the application.
They're both fine.
But again, this
sounds really simple,
but it solves a lot of problems.
If you give data to
people in this form,
they're going to
know what it means.
Right?
It doesn't require a
lot of explanations.
Like, dates are pretty
obvious, source names
are pretty obvious, and
then they can, basically,
work through it pretty nicely.
Databases and files
can work together.
You'll have some people like,
we do everything with files,
or we do everything
with databases.
They do different things.
They serve different purposes.
So databases are good for
quickly finding a small amount
of data in a big data set.
So if I want to look up a little
bit of data in a big data set,
that's what databases do well.
Likewise, if I want
to read a ton of data,
like all of the data,
and I want it analyzed,
that's what file
systems do well.
So you, a lot of times,
keep them both around.
You have databases for looking
up little elements quickly,
and you have data
and file system
if I want to read a lot of data.
So they work together
very harmoniously, they
serve different purposes.
And again, different databases
are good for different things.
I won't belabor these, you
can read them yourself.
But there are a variety
of database technologies
out there, and they
serve different purposes.
So let me talk about the folder
structure in a little bit
more detail.
This is getting really like--
It is really just this simple.
When we talk about
our standard pipeline,
it's just a bunch of
folders that we name,
like we show on the right.
So we have an overall folder
that we usually call pipeline,
and then we basically label
each step with step 0, step 1,
so people know which is the
beginning and which is the end
and what's happening in there.
So we have step 0 raw,
step one parse, step two
ingest, step three query,
step four analysis,
step five is viz, if
you're doing that.
And then, within each one of
those, we'll have a folder,
we'll have a readme, which
basically tells people
something about, OK,
what's going on there.
Those readmes are really good.
Even if you never share
this data with anybody else,
as you get on in
life, you will often
be asked to revisit
things, and just
having this information so
that two years later, you
can go back and look at it,
is really, really helpful.
Because otherwise,
you'll discover
that you don't remember
what it is you were doing.
So you write a
little readmes that
give you some information
about what's going on.
And then, within
each step, there's
usually readme that
talks to you about what
the instructions in here.
And then, we have
a folder called
code and folder called data.
And basically, the
code describes how
you put data into this folder.
So in the step 0 raw, this
is often the code, maybe,
for downloading the
data from the internet
or how you collected your data.
That's the code that, basically,
puts the data into that folder.
And then, with the
next folder here,
parse, this is the code
that takes this raw data
and parses it and puts
it into this folder.
And then, for
ingest, this will be
the code that takes the
data from the parse form,
sticks it in a
database, and these
might be the log files
of the database entry.
So a lot of times, when you
just data into a database,
you'll have log files that keep
track of what that happened.
And likewise, this
continues on down.
So very simple.
And I would offer to you, if
you someone gave you this,
and you looked at it,
without any documentation,
you'd probably have a pretty
good idea of what's going on.
Oh, this is some
kind of pipeline.
I wonder where it begins.
Probably step 0.
I wonder what that is.
It's probably raw data.
Right?
It's that simple.
And this just makes it so easy.
The more you can
get stuff to people
and they can just
understand it without
any additional explanation,
that's incredibly valuable.
And again, allows your teams to
contribute quickly to projects.
And then, finally, we'll
add a little thing here,
which is a data file list.
This is a list of the
full names of all the data
files because, especially
on our systems,
people are often processing
lots of data, which
contain millions of files.
If you're going to be using
many processors to do that,
it really punishes
the file system
if you ask 1,000 processors to
all traverse a data directory
and build up the file name
so they can figure out which
files they should each process.
Really, that's
actually a great way
to get kicked off a
computer is to have
1,000 processes all
doing ls-l on all
the folders in a new directory
with millions of files.
Right, it will bring the
file system to its knees.
So if you just
have this one file
that you generate
once that lists
all the names of the files,
then every single process
can just read into
that file, pick
which files they want to
read, and then do their work,
and then even know what the
names to write the files are.
And that's, really,
a very efficient way.
It dramatically speeds
up your processing
and keeps the pressure on
the file system at a minimum.
In addition, if you just want
to look at what you have,
you don't have to type ls
to list the directory, which
might ls while.
You can just look at this
file and see what do I have.
Right?
It's very convenient to be able
to know what the data sets are.
And then you can go
in there, and you see,
oh, I see all these, you
know, time stamps and sources.
I know what I have.
Right?
It makes it really easy for
people to get through this.
So finally, I want to talk
about using and sharing.
And so, again, co-design is
using and sharing together.
Most data that you will deal
with starts out unusable
and unshareable,
that is, the data
is not suited for the purpose
that you wanted to use it for,
and you do not have permission
to share with anybody.
And so, if you understand
the data and its purpose,
you can get through
both of those problems.
So, really practical aspects,
here, of data sharing.
We're going to talk about a
few different roles that are
very common in data sharing.
The first is the
keeper of the data.
This is the actual person
who has the ability
to make a copy of the data.
You can talk to lots of
people, but until you
find the keeper of the data, you
haven't really gotten anywhere.
Right?
Because lots-- Oh, yes, we
have data, and we can share it,
or we can give it
to you, et cetera.
And there's someone who
can eventually type a copy
command to the data.
You want to find that person.
That's the person you
really need to work with.
They're the one person who
can really, really help you
because they actually have
hands on access to the data.
So you want to find that.
Then, you want to get a
sample or a copy of the data
to your team to assess.
It is always good to
do good opsec, which
is good operational security,
which means fewer accounts,
fewer people having
access is better.
A lot of times people
say, oh, here's the data.
Give me a list of names that
you want to have access to it.
If you provide them one name,
that's often pretty easy
to get approved.
If you provide 10 names,
now questions will happen.
Why are we giving 10
people access to this data?
You don't really need 10 people
to have access to the data.
You can just have one person get
the data on behalf of the team.
That's relatively
easy to approve.
You start giving a list of
20 names have access data,
now there's all
kinds of questions,
and that may just end
the exercise right there.
And once the question starts
happening, you'll discover,
well, maybe we've lost
that one, and we need
to move on to someone else.
And guess what, that
keeper, do they like you now
that they've raised
all kinds of questions
because of something
they thought was OK?
Well, now we're--
No, you may no
longer have a friend.
Right?
So you've lost a friend,
you've lost a source of data,
so minimizing the
access to the data,
getting just the
people access to it who
need you to make your next
step is a really good practice.
I have been that keeper.
I have been the person
who has to approve things,
and nothing makes me
shut something down
quicker than when someone says,
well, I want 20 people to have
accesses.
I'm like, well, no.
Zero works for me.
That's a number in 20.
(LAUGHS) Right?
That's one of the
numbers, there.
How about zero?
That works for me.
So then, once you get
a copy of the data,
you then convert a sample
of it to a tabular form,
you can identify the useful
columns or features in that,
and then you can
get rid of the rest.
That's a huge service
to your community
is if you have a volume of
data, and you know, like,
all of this stuff is
not going to be useful.
Now you're just giving
people useful data.
That's really, really valuable.
That's sort of a --
And since you're talking
the keeper of the data,
they may have the
most information
about what these different
columns or features mean.
That's not a conversation
that a lot of people
are going to get to have.
And so, if you get to help
your whole team by saying,
oh we know these
columns mean this.
They're not relevant,
let's get rid of them.
That's a huge service
to your community.
It's less data.
It makes it easier to release.
You then, maybe, will, if there
is data columns or features
that are sensitive
in some way, there's
a variety of techniques you
can use to minimize, anonymize,
possibly simulate, or use
surrogate information to make
it so that you can
share that data.
And there's lots of
techniques, but those
are only applicable when
you know your application.
So if I look at this data,
and I see this one column that
might be sensitive but
valuable for my application,
I can often come up
with a minimization
scheme that will work for that.
Because all data
analysis is based
on tables, which is
mathematically just matrices,
one of the most
fundamental properties
of matrices that we
really, really like is
that reordering the
rows or the columns
doesn't change any of the math.
That's kind of, like, the big
deal of matrices and tables.
You can move the row,
reorder the rows,
reorder the columns, and
everything should still just
work, which means if
you relabel the columns
or leave relabel the rows,
things should still just work,
and you'll be able to
do the science you need.
So a lot of times, when you
share data with researchers,
information that normally
you would delete,
that you would think would be
valuable for someone else--
The researcher is
like, I don't care.
Right?
As long as it doesn't
change something fundamental
about the structure of the
data, I can work with that.
And again, that's
something you would never
know unless you have
an end purpose in mind.
So then, you want to obtain
preliminary approval to take--
I have a data set, I've
worked with the keeper,
is it OK for me to share this
with a broader set of people
to make sure that
they like it too?
That's usually easy to do.
It's just a small sample.
And then, you can test
with your AI users.
You repeat this process until
you, basically, have data.
It's like, yeah,
this is what we want,
this is what we want to share,
and then, you can sort of
go through the process
of how do we really get
an agreement in
place to do that.
You also, then,
create the folder
naming structure for scaling
out to more data files.
And then finally,
what's great is
if you can then automate this
process at the data owner's
site.
It's tremendously valuable.
Then you have just gifted
them a data architecture
that makes their data AI ready.
And then, moving
forward, they can now
share with you, within their own
organization, or with others.
Right?
So this is incredibly valuable.
Right, we said data architecture
and wrangling is often
80% of the effort.
You do this, you've now
eliminated potentially
80% of the effort
of anyone else who
ever wants to do data
analysis or AI in this data.
Right?
This is a phenomenally
huge win for anyone
that you partnered with is to
give them a very simple data
architecture they can
maintain going forward.
It's a huge potential
savings to them.
All right, so another
role we want to talk about
is the data owner subject
matter expert, or SME.
So we've talked about
the keeper of the data.
There's often a
subject matter expert
associated with the data
that is an advocate.
The keeper is often like,
hey, I maintain the data.
I do with these subject
matter experts tell me to do.
But there's someone
out there who
wants to help you get the
data because they see it's
going to be valuable to you.
And all these AI data products
are generally best made
by people with AI knowledge.
So we are highly
motivated to engage
with these subject
matter experts,
pull them into the
AI community so they
can see the best practices.
That will allow
them to understand
which data they have, how
it might be useful to AI,
and how to prepare
it, so that's better.
So whenever we get engaged
with subject matter experts
at other communities,
at data owners,
we really want to pull
them into the community,
have them come to
our environments
so they can see what's going on
and help us identify new data
sets and help make
those data sets
appropriate for our consumption.
So one of the big
things you'll run into
is that there are concerns
with sharing data.
That is, there's
a lot of confusion
about the liability of
sharing data with researchers.
And data owners often have
to think about the lowest
common denominator.
If it's a company,
they have to think
about US and EU and
other requirements,
all kinds of
different frameworks
for thinking about that.
The good news is there are
standard practices that
meet these requirements.
And I'm going to list what
these standard practices are.
We have worked
with many folks who
have tried to share
data successfully,
and these are the properties
of successful data sharing
activities.
And the activities that
don't do these things often
are unsuccessful.
We didn't invent any of this.
This is just our observations
from working with many people
who've tried to share data.
One, you want data available
in curated repositories.
Just taking data and
posting it somewhere
without proper curation really
does no good for anyone.
You want to use standard
and anonymization
methods where needed.
Hashing, sampling,
simulation, I've already
talked about those, but those
do work, particularly when they
are coupled with access
requires registration
with a repository
and legitimate need.
So there's a data
agreement associated
with getting the data in
some way, shape, or form.
And those two together
really, really work well.
And you also want
to focus on getting
the data to the people
who are actually
going to add value to it.
So one of the misnomers is,
oh, we'll just take data,
and we'll make it available
to all 10 billion souls
on the planet earth, when,
really, less than 100
could ever actually
add value to us.
So why are we going through
all the trouble and the issues
associated with making data
available to anyone, when
really we only want to get that
data to people with the skills
and legitimate research
needs to make use of it?
And so, by setting up
curated repositories,
people then apply--
I want to get access to data--
they talk about
what their need is.
That sets, sort of, a swim lane.
You can't just do anything
you want with the data.
When you say, I'm going to
use it for this purpose,
you have to stick
to those guidelines.
If you want to change them, you
have to go back and say, look,
I want to do
something different.
If you're a
legitimate researcher
with legitimate research needs,
that's usually pretty easy
to approve.
And then, recipients agree not
to repost the whole data set
or to deanonymize it.
This is what makes
anonymization work.
Not that the anonymization
or the encryption
is so strong it's
unbreakable, it's
that people agree
not to reverse it.
And the good thing about working
with legitimate researchers
is they're highly motivated
not to break their agreements.
If you're at MIT or any
of these universities
and you break your data
sharing agreements,
that is professionally
very detrimental to you
because it is very detrimental
to the organization.
No research or
organization ever wants
to have a reputation that it
does not respect its data usage
agreements.
That will put that research
organization out of business.
So there's a lot of incentive
for legitimate researchers
to honor these
agreements, which may not
be the same for just general
people who are working
in other types of environments.
So they can publish their
analysis and data examples
as necessary, they agree
to cite the repository
and provide the
publications back,
and the repository can
curate enriched products.
So if a researcher discovers
some derivative product--
Look, I can apply
this to all the data.
I'd like to have that
be posted somewhere.
They can often use the
original repository to do that.
And again, we encourage
everyone to encourage people
to follow these guidelines.
They're very beneficial.
So I've talked about
the data keeper.
I've talked about the
subject matter expert.
Now, I'm going to talk about
a final critical role, which
is the ISO, the information
security officer.
In almost every single
organization that has data,
there is an information
security officer
that needs to sign off on making
the data available to anyone
else.
They're the person whose
neck is on the line
and is saying that it's
OK to share this data,
that the benefits outweigh
the potential risks.
And subject matter experts
need to communicate the info
with the information
security officer.
They're often the ones
advocating for this data
to be released, but they don't
know the language information
security officers.
And this causes huge problems.
And, I would say, 90%
of data sharing efforts
die because of miscommunication
between subject matter experts
and information
security officers.
Because the information
security officer fundamentally
needs to believe that
the subject matter
expert understands the risks,
understands basic security
concepts in order for them to
trust them with their signature
to get it released.
And so, typically,
what happens is
that an ISO needs a very basic
information from the subject
matter expert in
order to approve
the release of information.
What's the project?
What's the need?
Where is the data going to be?
Who's going to be
using it for how long?
They are expecting one sentence
answers to each of these.
A subject matter
expert typically
replies with an entire
research proposal.
And so, if I'm an
ISO and I'm trying
to assess whether a subject
matter expert knows anything
about security, and I gave them
really easy softball questions,
and they come back
with something
that clearly took them
way more time and effort
that answers none of
my questions, what's
my opinion going to be of
that subject matter expert
and how much I
should trust them?
It's going to be zero.
And from that moment
onward, I'll be polite but,
you know, how about zero data?
That works for me.
(LAUGHS) Right?
That's a good number, right?
So this is really important.
And so, if there's
one thing we can do--
Because very few
of you are ISOs.
And something that my team
gets involved on a lot
is to intercept this
conversation before it goes
bad, is we can help
you work with ISOs,
work with people who have
to release with data,
and help answer these
questions in a proper way.
And so, I'm going to go
through a few examples, here.
So, a really common question
is, what is the data
you're seeking to share?
So this is a very
common question
to get back from an ISO.
Describe the data to be
shared, focusing on its risk
to the organization if it were
to be accidentally released
to the public or
otherwise misused.
Very common question.
And so, here's an
example answer.
Very short answer.
The data was collected
on these dates
at this location in
accordance with our mission.
The risk has been
assessed and addressed
by an appropriate
combination of excision,
anonymization,
and/or agreements.
The release to appropriate
legitimate researchers
will further our mission and
is endorsed by leadership.
Very, very, very short
answer, but we've
covered a lot of ground
in that short answer.
And I will explain.
Sentence one establishes
the, identity finite scope,
and proper collection of
the data in one sentence.
Sentence two establishes
that risk was assessed
and that mitigations were taken.
Sentence three establishes the
finite scope of the recipients,
an appropriate reason for
release, and mission approval.
We've covered-- we've answered
nine questions in three
sentences at the level
of detail an ISO wants.
An ISO can always ask you more
questions for more detail,
and they're usually looking for
another one sentence answer.
And you build these
up to be three, four,
five sentence things
that cover broadly
what you're wanting to do.
And you see here, you
don't want to do anything
that requires the ISO to have
detailed technical knowledge
of what you're doing.
They're looking for overall
scope, overall limiters
on what you're doing
so that is somehow
contained to a reasonable risk.
Another question, here, that's
very common is where, to whom
is the data going?
So please describe the
intended recipients.
So an example answer is the data
will be shared with researchers
at a specific set
of institutions,
that it will be processed
on those institution's
own systems, meaning their
institutions security policies,
which include password
controlled access,
regular application of
system updates, encryption
of mobile devices,
such as laptops,
all provided access to data will
be limited to personnel working
as part of this effort.
Again, we've covered a
lot of ground very simply.
We didn't really go
into too many details
that are specific to
this particular case.
And then, a final one is
what controls are there
on further release,
either policy or legal?
So an example is an
acceptable use guidelines
that prohibit attempting to
deanonymize the data will
be provided to all personnel
working on the data,
publication guidelines
have been agreed to that
allow for high-level statistical
findings to be published,
but prohibit including any
individual data records.
A set of notional
records has been
provided that can be published
an example of the data format
but is not part of
the actual data set.
The research agreement
requires that all data
be deleted at the
end of the engagement
except those items
retained for publication.
I'm not saying you
have to use this.
But again, this
is another example
of what ISOs are expecting.
You give them language like
this, their confidence swells.
They're like, ah, I'm
dealing with someone
that understands the risks
I'm taking on their behalf.
And we can move forward
in a very productive way.
And if you ever have questions
about how to do this,
feel free to talk to
my team or other people
or other ISOs who've
had to deal with this.
We actually are
working with a lot
of people on this language, a
lot of people the government,
to sort of get these
best practices out there.
We have socialized this with
a fair number of experts
in this field, and
there's general consensus
this is a very good method
for helping you get data out.
So that brings me to
the end of the talk.
So as I said before, data
wrangling is very important,
significant part of the effort.
Analysis really relies
on tabular data,
so that's a really good format.
You can do it in very simple,
non-proprietary formats.
You're going to have
to name your folders
and file something,
you might as well
name something that's
really generally usable.
And then, finally,
co-designing, the sharing,
and what the intent is at
the same time, that's doable.
Generalized release of
data is very, very hard.
Tailored release for
specific applications
is very, very doable if you
have good communication from all
the stakeholders involved.
So these are just
really practical things.
This isn't, sort of, fancy AI.
This is, sort of,
bread and butter,
how do you actually
get data analysis done.
And with that, I'm happy
to take any questions.